totalement scandaleuse on a une crise
sanitaire économique sociale les ménages
peinent à boucler leur budget avec la
hausse de l'inflation avec la hausse des
coûts de l'énergie et on les enfonce
encore plus au lieu des aider à trouver
une solution en leur disant vous allez
être en impayés de loyer on va vous
pénaliser encore plus on va faire une
procédure très courte on va mettre à
terre tous les dispositifs de prévention
et en plus vous pourrez aller en prison
voilà c'est totalement ça scandaleux on
n'a pas d'autre lieu
alors
on vous pose la question également chez
vous et c'est vrai que ça ça fait
énormément parler et c'est vrai que la
loi va être durcie pour les squatteurs
Mathieu tu lui dis non tu n'es pas
d'accord mais déjà c'est horrible on est
en train d'assimiler en fait SDF à des
personnes on va créer des SDF si on
empêche des personnes de voler le bien
de personnes qui ont travaillé pour
avoir ce bien pardon moi je suis pas en
train de dire qu'ils vont le mauvais
rôle qu'il faut mettre des gens dans la
rue il faut créer des logements sociaux
il faut s'organiser pour que les gens
savent pas dans la rue mais c'est pas
aux personnes qui ont payé toute leur
vie pour avoir pendant 20 ans une
hypothèque pour s'acheter un appartement
de faire en sorte qu'il y ait plus SDF
dans la rue je ne comprends même pas
comment on peut on peut discuter de ce
sujet en fait il faut absolument on l'a
vu on est plein de cas ici il faut il
faut que la loi soit beaucoup plus
sévère là-dessus pour que le squat
n'existe plus vous n'êtes pas là non
mais c'est le monde à l'envers en fait
on est d'accord avec le coup de gueule
de RFI c'est le monde à l'envers on a
peur que cette loi elle crée des SDF
mais des SDF il y en a déjà à cause du
squat ce sont les propriétaires donc
c'est n'importe quoi alors oui c'est
triste de mettre des gens dehors mais ça
me paraît quand même normal qu'on
priorise les gens qui sont des
propriétaires et ça m'énerve parce qu'à
force de vouloir protéger des gens qui
sont quand même dans l'illégalité faut
le rappeler on fragilise toute une
partie de la population qui sont des
honnêtement donc franchement on marche
sur la tête c'est n'importe quoi
Castaldi évidemment on parle
d'occupation illicite ils sont hors la
loi je comprends même pas que ça fasse
débat effectivement ils sont inquiets
pour ceux qui sont dans un dans un
appartement qui veut pas payer on va
dire voilà ils seront dehors ça c'est
autre chose c'est pas un occupation
illicite est-ce qu'il y a ah oui
quelqu'un comprend
j'avais le même problème je me demandais
c'est qui moi
moi je trouve que c'est encore de la
démagogie tout ça parce qu'au final
qu'on voit toutes les personnes qui sont
dans la rue et qu'on se pose la question
au logement et de créer des logements
pour toutes les personnes qui en ont
besoin plutôt que voler les logements de
personnes qui ont travaillé comme dit
Mathieu toute leur vie ça me perturbe
propriétaire voilà c'est ça en fait je
préfère qu'on reloge les personnes qui
en ont besoin plutôt que voler la
propriété des gens qui travaillent toute
leur vie est-ce que vous entendez
Gilbert
maintenant vous voulez parler avant ou
après Gilbert franchement on va le
laisser
vous allez mettre des familles à la rue
c'est ça que vous voulez les familles
avec des enfants à la rue et les
familles
les voleurs il faut ces familles là bien
sûr qu'elles doivent reprendre leur
logement mais elles sont beaucoup moins
nombreuses que je te dis toi tu veux
tout le monde exactement
pour que le propriétaire soit à la rue
et que le squatteur reste dans la maison
du propriétaire
la loi en France je vais vous dire tu
t'en vas 40 plus de 48 heures de chez
toi quelqu'un vient squatter ta maison
il change les serrures tu peux plus les
virer exactement est-ce que c'est toi et
normal pour vous
ce que vous dites aucun rapport avec la
loi quand on lit la loi le problème de
la loi je vais vous expliquer Cyril
c'est que expliquer de la marque
il y a une procédure d'expulsion Express
vous rendez compte le mot expulsion
Express qui fait qu'on ne va même plus
recourir à un juge le juge qui était là
pour dire oui ou non maintenant la
première personne
et le couple de retraités qui a vécu
pendant des années dans son camp
de famille et d'enfants à la rue mais
ceux qui sont propriétaires et qui sont
déjà à la rue le problème Gilles ton
problème à toi Gilles c'est que tu
défonces c'est que tu juge tout non mais
pardon tu juges tout le temps avec ta
vie à Paris avec un beau salaire et tout
est déjà là alors tu juges et tu
commentes mais encore une fois c'est
comme le cambriolage si ça t'arrivais
Gilles si ça t'arrivait que tu étais
dehors de la rue si tu étais dehors dans
la rue parce que ton appartement
que t'étais dehors dans une caravane à
Boulogne qu'est-ce que tu ferais Gilles
qu'est-ce que tu ferais pas de problème
il peut se reloger là on est bien
d'accord
propriétés privées est inscrite dans la
Constitution on va pas c'est n'importe
quoi
il y a un mec qui soit chez toi tu le
fous pas dehors mais Cyril à chaque fois
vous me renvoyez ça
chez toi pareil dans les cambriolages
mais non mais ça c'est pas assez
hypothétique tu vis dans la théorie dans
la théorie la pratique
merci Monsieur bravo il y a le mec de
Mathieu qui déconnecte
[Applaudissements]
merci Monsieur
alors à vous je vous réponds avec
plaisir s'il y avait un squatteur chez
moi jamais je ne le jetterai dehors je
ferai appel à la pause
et je réponds au monsieur si jamais
j'accueillais ce qui est sans doute
peut-être le cas des gens qui n'ont pas
de papier je pourrais pas le dire en
public parce qu'on pourrait venir les
chercher pour les déloger mais je sais
que oui je vais vous le dire oui j'ai
accueilli déjà des gens sans papiers
chez moi voilà voilà et ça je le
revendique Cyril ça je le revendique
voilà
quel rapport
avec les gens qui ont une propriété qui
ont travaillé 20 ans pour 2000 balles
par mois avec un emprunting
vous qui confondez
pas des mecs qui sont venus chez toi
non mais c'est vrai que tu confonds tout
Gilles c'est vous qui font confondez
tout contre les squatteurs et contre les
loyers impayés dehors des gens qui ne
payent pas leurs loyers ils viennent
chez toi ils te disent là on est chez
nous ils ont changé la serrure tu vas
faire quoi tu vas leur donner à manger
police
le petit coup de retraité typiquement
moi je les ai en tête encore j'avais
tout bien sûr des polices
que elle elle se fasse dégager en fait
plus vite que prévu moi je parlais de
cette loi
le problème il est simple tu te
rappelles des deux retraites qui ont été
foutus dehors parce que des gens on
squattait chez eux qui se sont retrouvés
à vivre dans une caravane et encore
parce qu'ils avaient quelques économies
et avec un cancer malade exactement donc
c'est ça l'histoire donc eux on veut
protéger comme ça voilà pour des gens
comme ça qui sont en train de faire
cette loi portable mais toi tu tournes
encore autour du pot et tu dis encore
des trucs qui sont inaudibles excuse-moi
parce que moi voir des gens qui ont
passé toute leur vie à travailler
pour propriétés c'est nous qui se
retrouvent à la rue et qui se trouve
avec des gens qui leur fracassent leur
maison parce que quand ils leur ont dans
un état lamentable s'il aura deux trois
ans quatre ans après donc ça toi tu fais
rien toi si tu regardes écoute-moi là
vraiment tu te trompes pas mon chéri là
comme la jeune fille qui était venue qui
avait perdu sa maman
et c'est toi qui c'est toi qui choisis
de les recueillir il n'a rien à faire
alors casse la serrure
ils prennent l'adresse ils se font
envoyer du courrier tu en as pour deux
ans c'est fini Cyril si vous me dites
que je dis n'importe quoi pourquoi alors
par rapport à cette loi est-ce que
toutes les associations qui aident les
gens sont contre s'élèvent et dit c'est
n'importe quoi
parce qu'elles ont lu la loi et qu'on
pourra jeter des familles dehors avec
des enfants à n'importe quel moment
parce que c'est politique c'est juste
aujourd'hui
sont pas politisés c'est faux c'est
quand même hyper politique
aujourd'hui voilà de faire en sorte
qu'il puisse dans la rue c'est très
triste SDF personnel le contraire mais
c'est pas aux gens qui ont travaillé
pour ça je donne un appartement au bout
de 20 bien sûr ce problème là
[Musique]
d'autant plus que si pardon la loi
prévoit déjà trois ans de prison vous
vous rendez pas compte
[Musique]
les gens c'est récupérer leur maison
tout de suite le plus c'est pas attendre
encore
des années des années dehors exactement
donc tu as le droit ou tu prends 3 ans
de prison faut déjà que ça va durer des
années déjà avant qu'ils prennent il les
prendront jamais et les gens seront
dehors les gens qui sont propriétaires
donc une fois de plus de loyer payé que
j'ai toujours
ce pays j'aime la France vraiment je le
dis à chaque fois j'aime les Français je
trouve des c'est des gens formidables
voilà et que je me dis un moment il y a
des gens comme toi je te jure qui sont
des gens et que j'adore en plus dans la
vie mais qui sont des gens qui font
reculer la France et qui par leur
immobilisme et et et qui qui veulent
faire plaisir à un moment tu peux pas
faire plaisir à tout le monde moi
j'aimerais que tout le monde soit moi
aussi j'aimerais que tout le monde soit
logé
c'est génial ça je trouve ça vraiment
super mais tu peux pas cautionner des
mecs qui viennent casser la porte qui
viennent habiter chez toi qui
connaissent très bien les lois et qui
derrière se sert de ton à ta maison pour
dire et ben non maintenant c'est chez
moi ça quand il y a des mecs qui ont
passé toute leur vie à travailler et qui
se retrouvent dehors tu deviens fou
écoute-moi bien un peu tu deviens fou et
ça tu ne peux pas le cautionner
excuse-moi je suis désolé
tu protèges toujours les délinquants
dans tous les sujets sont
tous merci Gilles là Cyril c'est facile
que vous me dites vous me renvoyez ah tu
cautionnes que les squators rentre chez
les gens c'est pas ce que je dis votre
question est-ce que tu dis sur cette
nouvelle loi avec des expulsions c'est
bon mais c'est ça c'est le plus
important c'est ça de la loi je veux pas
qu'on puisse être toujours dans la
théorie j'ai toujours dans la théorie
mais oui avant trois pas en arrière et
si le squatteur paye pas le loyer donc
il est de mauvaise foi on peut payer le
loyer est-ce que tu es pour ou contre la
trêve hivernale oui je suis pour qu'un
juge tranche pour le dégager en fait
parce que je vois pas pourquoi le petit
propriétaire lui doit dormir dehors ou
dans une carence des familles à la rue
des fraternité appropriétaires qui lui a
payé dehors plutôt que la personne qui
n'a pas payé dehors pourquoi c'est celui
qui a payé qui doit être dehors
le propriétaire il a une famille aussi
le problème c'est que Gilles tu
raisonner tes moyens donc tu défends les
propriétaires
attention j'espère pour toi alors Cyril
ça c'est pas gentil ce que vous voyez
j'espère pour toi est-ce que je peux
faire un petit aparté quand je dis ça
quand je défends mes positions que je
défends à cœur vous le savez mais tu as
raison
j'ai pas de problème en tout cas très
très courageux et heureusement qu'il est
là parce que si tout le monde disait non
il y a plein de gens qui disent comme
vous comme Matthieu aller chez lui
cambrioler le donc si on peut éviter ça
y a rien à cambrioler
ça a déjà été cambriolé l'année dernière
donc c'est bon mais ce que je dis j'ai
surtout c'est que si l'arrivée quelque
chose à quelqu'un autour de la table ici
malgré tout on est très privilégié on
ira chez quelqu'un dans une famille on
ira à l'hôtel on s'en sortirait mais les
gens dont on parle euh ils n'ont rien
Gilles ils sont pas comme toi ils n'ont
pas de salaire ils ont rien d'autre ils
sont à la rue parfois ils n'ont pas de
famille ils sont dans une caution eux
n'ont rien Gilles on parle pas de gens
aisés qui sont dans la merde parce que
leur appartement est occupé tu vois ce
que je veux dire plein de gens qui ne
pètent je ne comprends pas que toi qui
aime à ce point justement les gens enfin
l'humain comme tu dis tu ne peut-être
pas les gens humains mais qui sont
innocents
tu parlais des gens qui ne payent pas
dans la rue moi je peux l'entendre ça
c'est à dire que si non mais attends
s'il y a une personne qui dit voilà il
va avoir le propriétaire dit voilà en ce
moment j'ai des très grosses difficultés
est-ce que monsieur vous pouvez me
laisser 3 4 mois pour me retourner et je
vais pas payer je suis sûr que tous les
propriétaires
si elle a une famille et il dirait oui
on va voir ça on verra ça plus tard il y
a pas de quoi moi ce que je n'aime pas
c'est les gens qui se servent de la loi
pour enfreindre et et rentrer chez toi
par effraction et te dire après ah bah
non maintenant c'est chez moi j'ai fait
j'ai reçu du courrier donc ça c'est pas
possible moi une personne qui peut pas
payer son loyer ça peut arriver je vous
dis il y a des gens qui les pauvres qui
ont eu des gros problèmes de santé qui
se retrouvent avec des mots très
difficiles qui dévissent ils vont voir
le propriétaire où il a pas du livre
voilà Monsieur pendant quatre cinq mois
est-ce qu'on peut essayer de s'arranger
et ça sache que je le comprends
complètement je suis pour ça il y a
aucun problème est-ce que tu dis un mec
qui se sert de la loi
parce que ils connaissent très bien la
loi qui rentre chez toi et qui dit bah
maintenant c'est chez moi et toi tu
restes dehors ça je peux dire que ça
c'est non c'est ça la loi doit porter
surtout sur ça je suis désolé qui
considère que quand on rentre chez toi
illégalement bah tu dois pas te défendre
c'est la logique c'est ça le problème
avec toi c'est que tu défends encore une
fois toujours la personne qui est qui
est malhonnête je peux vous poser une
question puisque vous me posez beaucoup
Mathieu les grands froid arrive
possiblement oui vous avez un domicile
chez vous je sais pas si vous êtes
locataire au propriétaire une famille
vous squatte avec un ou deux enfants oui
vous êtes squatter chez vous oui le
grand froid arrive cette famille si vous
pouvez vous l'acheter dehors pas grand
froid au risque que les enfants meurent
de grand froid dans la rue oh là alors
on n'est pas aussi bien ici
arrête un peu ils ont squatté chez lui
non est-ce qu'ils ont est-ce qu'ils sont
rentrés il est également chez lui
je suis désolé d'abord on n'est pas en
Sibérie donc il veut pas mourir de grand
froid on est à Paris quand même mais
mais quand même mais effectivement on
sait comment ça marche
avoir un tigre sur le périple
tu es tranquille dans le tu es
tranquille en centre-ville un crocodile
il y a eu un tigre non mais je te
réponds effectivement il y a très
hivernale on sait comment ça marche et
puis après à très vernal il va y avoir
des procédures qui font qu'on va arriver
encore à une très hivernale donc je te
réponds au risque que ces enfants est
très froid effectivement très vernal ou
pas je ferai tout pour expulser ces
personnes bien sûr moi jamais
merci Mathieu bocage